I rode shotgun in the lead Humvee and I
looked for bombs stop a chart you all
see the bomb unless they want me to what
you got I don't see nothing now you
don't see he feels it I was a good
soldier
I had purpose and I loved it you kick
some ass over there yeah yeah we wanted
it to be perfect I'm home with my
favorite girls it's perfect baby
am I getting my ear what oh yeah you're
getting late
maybe I'm foolish how long you been up
target 4 p.m. in Baghdad I want
chocolate chip smiley face pancake for
you
she doesn't like chocolate okay I guess
I miss that how Moni you too Army
Commendation medals and on the edge even
metal impressive you never told me you
were a hero don't spare me the details
I can take anything but quiet
real Rob you are my hammer out there
I'll let these young guys see you for
longer he did his job
nothing yours Oh monie monie go right no
I'm not right can't name her after me
he's too perfect
is there specific incident that troubles
you no Ravi no massage
[Music]
I know this don't look like much of a
life but every when I get up I'm
grateful I'm alive because he
thank you for looking after my son I'm
not a hero
we're brothers we look after each other
I'm only human after all don't put the
blame on me
[Music]
you